Hổ quốc phòng bàn hành thông tư một chăm niệng sấu, hợp ngày 3,5 năm, hành hành hủ chăm 20 năm,
quy định lại mua hình tổ chức khám tình và trận xức khỏe nghĩa vụ quân sự.
Đi mới là sức quy trình từ cấp sạ đến hộ đồng khu vực, ấn định thời hạn xử lý hộ sơ,
đồng thời cập nét tư trình khám mắt và cách phân rại thi lực.
Theo thông tư một chăm niệng sấu, hộ đồng khám xức khỏe khu vực là hộ đồng truyền môn kiếm giễm sốt chủ tịch
bàn nhân dân cấp tình thành lập được tổ chức khám đoàn khám, trường đoàn là phó chủ tịch hộ đồng.
Trạm ít tế cấp sạ sơ tình dưới sự chỉ đạo chuyên môn của sửi tế,
tổng hợp báo cáo và bàn xào vụ sơ cho hộ đồng giễ vụ quân sự cấp sạch,
trong 15 ngày sau khi kết thúc khám phải lập dành xe công dân đủ xức khỏe.
Trường hộ không đặt, sửi tế chỉ đạo đơn vị chuyên môn thông báo đưa ra khỏi dành xe xử bị.
Cuy định mối nêu gió quy trình khám mắt đò thiết lực chuẩn, dùng máy đò khúc sạch khi cần,
nghen tắc tính tổng thị lực khai mắt, ngống mời chiến trên mồi sau chính kiến,
cùng hướng giãn về mùa mở, bệnh lý mì mắt hóc mắt, mộ thiết và các tính điểm sạch lập nhàng bệnh tân thần.